(male announcer)
Teaching Center
is brought to you by BMW.
The ultimate driving machine.
[upbeat rock music]
♪ ♪
Hello and welcome
to Teaching Center.
I'm Boyd Maxwell,
with today's top stories
from the exciting world
of teaching.
And I'm Perry Schmidt.
Well, now we know.
The long awaited announcement
by star English teacher
Ruby Ruhf has sent teaching fans
across the nation into a frenzy.
I've enjoyed my time
in Ohio very much,
but I'm pleased to announce
that I'm taking my talents
back to New York City.
Thank you very much.
Apparently, PS431 has made Ruby
an offer she couldn't refuse.
$80 million guaranteed
over six years,
with another $40 million
in incentives
based on test scores.
This salary puts her
right up there
with Rockridge Elementary's
Katie Hope
and William Wu
out of--
Colgate Magnet!
All right, let's take a look
at yesterday's
high school teacher draft
from Radio City Music Hall,
where Central Rapids High,
recipient of the worst
test scores last semester,
made the first pick
that was no surprise to anyone.
[all cheering]
For the first pick,
Central Rapids High takes...
calculus teacher Mike Yoast
from Tulsa Teacher's College.
[all cheering]
(Key)
And just like that,
you're a millionaire. Ha ha.
(Peele)
Mike Yoast
is an unbelievable story,
his father living
from paycheck to paycheck
as a humble
pro football player.
Kid was a natural mathlete.
You know he's gonna buy
his mom a house.
- Oh, you know this.
- Oh, there's no way
- around that.
- [laughs]
You owe your mom.
[laughs]
(announcer)
Today's highlight of the day
is brought to you
by the 100% Black Angus Beef
Thickburger
on a fresh-baked bun
from Carl's Jr. and Hardee's.
Now it's time
for the highlight of the day.
[rock music]
Star history teacher
Ashley Ferguson has been
running up them test scores
over at Vinz Clortho High.
- Okay.
- Whoo.
Confederate forces
fired first.
Can anyone tell me
where this battle took place?
Now, look at this.
She looks left,
then right,
looks past the students
with their arms up in the air,
- spots Max near the back...
(Key) Whoo.
Sees that even though his hand
isn't up, he's engaged.
Max?
It was Fort Sumter?
That's right.
Oh, come on.
See what she did there?
She's bringing a introvert
into the discussion, y'all.
That's a teacher of the year
play right there.
That's right, Boyd.
You know, the confidence gained
by Max by answering
that question correctly
will enhance his performance
throughout the rest of the year.
No doubt.
Coming up after the break,
Mayfield Prep trades
French teacher Janeane Lowe
to Skyline High
for a head librarian
and two lunch ladies
to be named later.
And we'll get the inside scoop
on the impending
- teacher's strike that could...
- Uh-oh.
Cripple the season.
Next up,
on Teaching Center.
Whoo.
[rock music]
[dramatic music]
(Ruby voice-over)
Strength courses through me.
I am velocity.
I am power.
[school bell ringing]
♪ ♪
I am a leader,
a believer.
♪ ♪
I am the force that guides.
I am the gateway
to what is possible,
the path to the future.
I am the future.
♪ ♪
(male announcer)
The all-new 2015 6 Series
is here.
Meet the new Teacher's Pet.